well they are words that can only steam
an investigator in charge of this week's
school shooting in uvalda texas today
admitted that police made the wrong
decision
not to immediately enter the classroom
where the attack was still taking place
investigators say that the police
mistakenly thought that the situation
was that of a barricaded gunman and not
an active shooter situation and that was
despite multiple
911 emergency calls that had been made
from the school to emergency services
saying that students had already been
killed
authorities say that nearly 20 officers
stood in a hallway outside the classroom
for more than 45 minutes before
they used a master key to open the door
and finally confront the gun
let's listen now to what the director of
the texas department of public safety
said today
for the benefit of hindsight where i'm
sitting now
that of course it was not the right
decision it was a wrong decision period
there's no no excuse for that
but again i wasn't there but i'm just
telling you from what we know we believe
there should have been an entry at that
as soon as you can hey when there's an
active shooter the rules change it's no
longer okay
it's no longer a barricaded acceptance
you don't have time you don't worry
about outer primers
that was steven mccraw there the
director of the texas department of
public safety i want to go now to our
correspondent stefan simons he's been
covering this story for us the entire
week in texas he's still in texas
stefan i want to get your reaction to
what we discovered today i mean we are
talking about a major
major
error in judgment and a breakdown in
communication with the police
yeah i can tell you that there's a lot
of people out there who who don't have
the kindest words for
uh what they
listen to and what they learned today
from the police
um
and of course we can't repeat them but
i can tell you that there is
outrage on the side of
the public in yuvalde and just imagine
the families they heard
they heard this for the first time too
so you lost your child
and three days in after all this
happened you're still grief stricken and
you want the world to end or the world
has ended for you
you get
a press conference from the police which
we had asked for for days and that's you
know that's a whole other story um
trying to get information information
now we know why they were not
forthcoming with information not because
they didn't have it
uh because they had a problem on their
hands and the people in uvalde and the
families are absolutely devastated with
this and why would they not that was a
major blunder and
again
for
45 minutes 19 officers in the hallway
were told by the commanding officer no
don't do anything because it's a
barricade situation uh people don't even
understand
why he was that how this thinking or
this assessment could have been done so
major mistake and outrage all along yeah
and then we learned today the chief of
police saying that he had the ultimate
authority it was his decision for those
those special agents to wait instead of
to go in
when they could have gone in and so of
course the question comes
if they had not waited so long
would we today be talking about
fewer
dead school children and maybe no dead
teachers in this instance
possibly possibly at least possibly and
you know it's it's
not about that i mean this is bad enough
that we have to ask this question did
this police operation go so wrong did
this
leading police officer and and
surrounding officers because you know i
mean
if one guy just because he has another
star on his shoulder pat makes the wrong
decision and i know that as a police
officer as a trained police officer then
i need to i need to say something and i
need to this is not uh
mutiny but i need to say something and
try to move this mind or this officer to
make the right decision and he made the
wrong decision yeah are we is it
possible that we that they could have
lives been saved children's lives been
saved to the teachers yes possible there
were 9-1-1 calls begging the police
begging the police to actually jump into
action because the kids heard the police
that in the next door in the hallway and
nothing happened it is
it's mind-boggling and it is
mind-boggling and we know now you're on
your way to houston texas the national
rifle association's annual convention
takes place
today and because of what has happened
this week we we know
some politicians have canceled their um
speeches including the texas governor
um but not everything has been canceled
the former u.s president he's on
his way to speak
talk to me about the juxtaposition of
all of that against
this school shooting
yeah what what what can anyone say i
mean there is uh
the truth is mr abbott the governor of
texas he canceled his personal
appearance he's still dropping a
pre-taped video message to the nra ted
cruz senator
ted cruz from texas
is not withdrawing his participation
tonight he will show up
at the convention president trump as you
mentioned former president trump
is going to come this all looks so bad
it's bad optics it's probably also bad
politics it is
it is also incomprehensible because it
is you know for those parents or for
people in in uvalde we talk to not just
parents but all citizens there you can
go on the street here i mean in san
antonio and ask somebody and they tell
you
they don't understand it they don't they
really don't get it i think people a lot
of people have trouble understand why
the nra thought it's still a good idea
to go forward with this
and i don't have an answer for this
because all we hear is uh is headshaking
and unbelievable people are
and really in shock that this is still
going down there and another thing
another another thing that shocking
we've got we've got about half a minute
just want to ask you i know you've
talked to lots of politicians
senator ted cruz from texas was asked
this week about american exceptionalism
and the fact that there are so many gun
mass shootings in the u.s and his
response was you obviously don't like
the us if you're posing the question i
mean we can't get lawmakers to admit
that there is a crisis
how do americans explain that americans
see what's going on
yeah they do um i really have to let's
take the emotion out of this fact is
that
republican
politicians or let's say politicians who
are still seeing the tune of we don't
need more gun restrictions we don't need
red flag laws we don't need any
improvement to this
they are responding to a clientele in
america who which is big it's a it's a
lot of people they do not want to mess
with guns in what way in that way that
they think that any restriction in terms
of background controls or reflect laws
could impede on their
god-given constitutionally
constitutionally given right to bear
arms and that is so entrenched in the
american culture you have the right to
bear arms that they feel they need to
protect this by all might so they
overshoot somehow politicians maybe too
and don't forget nra and the gun lobby
these are big big and deep pockets yeah
and there is a lot of politicians in
texas but everywhere in the u.s they
like that money for their campaigns
yeah in many talks not only in texas our
correspondent stephen simon's on the
story for us tonight in the state of
texas as always stefan thank you